the show was on television for 15 years
there was a lot of you know
divide
amongst supernatural fandom about how
the show ended and what happened with
your character and you know there's a
divide yeah i'm sure you're aware of
this yeah what are your thoughts on it
um
i don't think there's a wrong opinion
about it i honestly don't i think that
if the people that have problems with it
are are validated and i think the people
that enjoyed it are validated i i was in
both camps
i spent time in both camps i've cried
every day for a week you really you
genuinely cry yeah i read the script
every day
um
and even just moments on set you know we
have
where we're filming our last episode so
every now and again we're at a location
it's like oh i've been here 15 years i
remember this place i remember where i
played my dog and this and that and it's
like okay this is the last time we'll be
at this location and i think to myself
there's a possibility i'm trying to be
aware of but i'll never make this drive
again the very first time
we had ever heard what was going to
happen at the end of the season
jared and i flew out to la
and we went to the writers room before
the season started
and they
the
they all sat we all sat down and they
essentially pitched us what
they how they wanted to to wrap up the
show
which was the first time in supernatural
history that that had ever happened uh
and what was your initial reaction my
initial reaction was i don't like it
here's what i'm trying to deal with
right now you know saying goodbye to a
friend of 15 years
the show you know my character sam like
i know so well and so the audience
actually got to watch these two
characters jared and jensen
that jared and jensen were playing
grow up as those actors grew up like you
see those the first season of that show
and they're kids yeah and
you know when the show ended they were
washed up
and
i've never gone i'm going off on tangent
a little bit i've never gone five months
without playing sam winchester not since
i was 22 years old and i'm 38 now with a
wife and three kids
and gray hairs they have to scratch out
with a comb uh very humbling
so i slept on it and
about a week went by and i just i went
to my wife and i was like i'm just
really bumping on this like i'm just
it's just not
and and she she was like is it is it
because
uh dean dies and i'm like maybe maybe
i'm just too close to that character and
i just don't want to see him go
and i i for some reason i always thought
that if if someone was gonna go it would
be
sam as
honestly as as kind of the
you know as the um
the martyr martyr i was thinking martyr
yeah and and and dean would then be left
to just kind
of stumble through the rest of his life
right mourning his brother and his lost
family and and and it would be
you know maybe a sad existence but
that's just how it how it happened or we
would both go like a butch and sundance
kind of a thing right it's been an
incredible journey to say the least i
for one am hoping that supernatural
never dies what did you mean by that
for which part i just want it to go on
forever in terms of the fans will always
remember in 30 years from now when i
walk into it you know
a supernatural and it will just always
be in people's minds and and new to new
generations is it that or is it be i'd
like to come back and do a supernatural
movie or maybe we'll do another season
someday who knows or is it a combination
of both uh yes yes yes and yes um
and i do feel like this is this isn't
like the long goodbye right now you know
this is
i feel like this is a
uh um
you know let's let's put this let's hang
this in the closet for now and and we'll
we'll dust her off you know down the
road so you couldn't come back i mean
the winchesters i mean you couldn't come
back in a supernatural spin-off or you
couldn't come back in a supernatural
movie dude it's supernatural
it's supernatural of course we could of
course we can and would you there's all
kinds of ways you would
uh it was the right thing if it was the
right 100
again i love i love
that this character and i love the story
of these two brothers and i love what it
what it stands for right and i love the
world that they live in
and the and the the family that they
have
acquired through their years like i just
there's there's so much love and
attachment to to that show there's it's
a reason that it went 15 years and it
could have gone longer and i think that
that we weren't terribly guarded with
the fans we were a little bit vulnerable
we're a little bit open a little bit
open-hearted um we were willing to you
know make an ass to yourself
make total asses of ourselves
humility
yeah and how emotional i could just see
two of you good-looking [ __ ] just
falling together oh my god sweating you
got the sauna you guys got the sauna
blanket over both of you you're just
crying your [ __ ] eyes out
here
it's already been emotional man you know
what's funny is that um i wasn't sad
um i was
it was emotional pride of like looking
back and like look at what we did
that's that was the feeling the
overwhelming feeling that i had was more
of like
look at this amazing thing that we built
right
that we did together
this is it was just just emotional pride
he and i both and you know this you
worked with him and you know me for a
long time and
he and i both are so
committed to these characters you know
he plays dean rochester i play sam
manchester like i love sam winchester
he's been my close friend for 15 years
and i want to do him justice so i'm
focusing really hard
i'm trying to focus really hard to make
sure that if sam cries it's sam tears
not jarrett's so you didn't tear up in
the last scene with jared this is our
last scene together
the
he didn't switch lines give each other a
kiss
no we we had we had well i hadn't he had
his hand in my pants but that was other
than that but that was below frame um
no the the
the final day we had kind of already
processed and it wasn't it wasn't really
a big emotional day
um
the emotional scene came a few days
earlier which was when dean dies and
says goodbye to sam and basically like
you got to let me go
that one was
that was heavy hard
oh yeah i mean he yeah he and i were
those were
those were it was
a strong mixture of
of
character performance tears and
actor emotional real tears
you